and so as many of you have seen Alex
Jones was back on the Joe Rogan show I
think it was it yesterday or two days
ago and it seems to be blowing up on the
Internet
I've been wanting to do a video on
conspiracy theory and using Alex Jones
as an example and so I thought that
because now all of this is going down it
might be a good opportunity to look at
how conspiracy theory functions in terms
of its symbolic structure
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Music]
[Applause]
so if you watched the podcast if not I
would suggest you do it is long it's
four hours long but it is worth watching
because through the crazy discussion and
that you know the extremely dramatic
presentation that Alex Jones gives there
are some interesting things that you can
get from what he says some interesting
things that can help you understand the
structure of reality and how things lay
themselves out first of all I have to
say that Alex Jones seems to be someone
who has a very good intuition about
things and he doesn't seem to have the
right language to express them he also
seems to be caught in what I would call
a kind of materialism which means that
he his symbolic intuition is always
pointed towards a kind of materialist
explanation and that is actually the
case about a lot of conspiracy theory if
you look at a lot of conspiracy theory
they tend to see the symbolic structure
their symbolism or or if they see
certain symbols appear instead of seeing
those symbols as pointing to principles
or pointing to patterns of reality they
tend to see them as only pointing
towards let's say specific historical
events or specific historical structures
and so I'll give you an example that is
very that happened to me not too long
ago I was visiting a church nearby a
Catholic Church and in the church in one
of the arches of the of the roof of the
ceiling there was eight an all-seeing
eye you know a triangle with an eye
inside and there was a man there we were
being given a tour by a tour guide and
there was a man who looked at the tour
guide and he said oh you know that that
means that this was built by by the
Illuminati and so you know I should
laugh you know a lot of people a lot of
people see it that way obviously that
church was not built by the Illuminati
some church in Quebec you know in the in
the 19th 18th 19th century was not built
by the Illuminati that symbol of the
all-seeing eye is a very ancient symbol
which we can find in medieval churches
we can find all kinds of
in all kinds of places it has a specific
meaning and whether or not the and it
was an image used to represent God
because God is an all-seeing eye and
whether or not it was used later by
Freemasons or by you know certain
certain organizations that is quite
possible but we cannot reduce the symbol
to its historical contingency it's the
same with the swastika a swastika does
not mean Nazis the swastika is a very
very ancient image which was one of the
oldest images we have and and the fact
that it was used by the Nazis does not
eliminate its ancient language its
ancient meaning because if you go to
medieval churches once again you will
find swastikas all over the place you
will find them I visited Calvin's Church
in Switzerland and there were swastikas
in the decoration it is a very very
ancient symbol which has a meaning a
meaning about witches goes beyond its
historical contingency okay so that's
first of all very important to
understand now despite that despite the
fact that Alex Jones seems to want to
see symbolism related to historical
contingencies which makes him end up
using all kinds of crazy language such
as multi-dimensional and and trying to
relate everything to some kind of
scientific hypothesis his intuition is
actually quite good in terms of
understanding symbolism if you haven't
watched the video I would suggest you do
because one of the things that happens
during the discussion with Joe Rogan is
that they end up talking about
conspiracy theory itself and the way
they talk about it can help you
understand what conspiracy is why
conspiracy theories appear and so
conspiracy theories the symbolism of
conspiracy theories is that it comes
about to show us that there is no longer
trust in the Innis structure there's no
longer trust within an authority
structure and so when when conspiracy
theories start to pop up you know even
beyond the way they pop up or the form
that they pop up what it points to is a
break down of social cohesion because we
start to doubt
the intentions of those in power we
start to see them as being hypocritical
to see them as lying and in the the
podcast yesterday it's very interesting
because Alex Jones at some point starts
to say that even himself at some point
had what he called a mild psychosis
because because the government you know
in the 20th century have lied so much to
us because they are now specific
examples of times when governments have
acted against their own people where
governments have said one thing and then
done another in secret because of that
now we have a general culture of doubt
whenever the government says something
whenever something happens there will be
people who will doubt the authenticity
of the events because it is because the
government has lied so much that it has
broken down the social cohesion so when
you remember for example someone like
someone like Jordan Peterson who talks
about how when you lie you lead the
world into hell now here is a very very
concrete example by by lying many times
in the past our state's our governments
have brought about a state of mistrust
towards their intentions and with that
what that's doing is creating breakdown
in social cohesion and it is encouraging
conspiracy theory even more and so so
even Alex Jones at some point he said
you know at some point he started to
doubt that anything was real that
everything that appeared in the media
anything any event was staged was that
there was something behind it which was
hidden that that was a conspiracy okay
and so that's a really important to
understand in terms of of conspiracy
theory and what conspiracy theory means
now what's interesting about Alex Jones
is ranting is when the social cohesion
breaks down you can imagine it as you
have a society that has a center that
has a common memory that has a common
identity that has you know a common
leadership
this is what creates an actual society
is that we are attached to a center or
to several centers which which are you
know acting together okay now once that
starts to break down we start to move
towards the periphery the periphery is
the place where multiplicity starts to
affirm itself and starts to break down
and then when that happens what what is
the result what is the result of that
breakdown in order two things one is a a
desire for tyranny a desire to create
something which will which will regain
control over the control that's been
lost and you can hear that in the
conspiracy theory about the notion of a
one-world government the idea of you
know a secret elite which is trying to
control our our society our culture
trying to control us and so you see in
the conspiracy theory a normal
understanding of what happens when
societal structures break down when the
center starts to to stop holding then
one of the reaction is to overcompensate
by a this type of control now the other
side is the fall into chaos the fall
into idiosyncrasy and then going up to
the margin of the world where all the
monsters are you know just like in the
ancient times we had this notion of the
monsters on the edge of the world then
you see that happen so in the conspiracy
theory it is not surprising that you
will find things like hybrids like
cannibalism like monsters like demons
like strangers aliens you know all of
that is going to almost necessarily
appear in the conspiracy theory because
that is what it looks like for a world
to break down let's look at those let's
look at those a few of those in
particular the biggest thing that Alex
Jones has said says and which causes
people to lose their mind is the idea
that you know are the
has been in contact with aliens for a
very long time you know and these aliens
are dictating to them what to do and the
aliens are asking for human sacrifice
and blood and all of this and and you
think like wow okay man you're you're
you it seems like he's losing it but
let's look at it let's look at it in
terms of what it's referring to okay if
you listen to Alex Jones very carefully
at some point you'll start to switch
between the the name that he gives to
these aliens he'll say alien then he'll
say something like elves and then he'll
say demons and so what is he talking
about what is he talking about now if we
want to understand it symbolically what
is what is happening as the world breaks
down from unity what ends up happening
is there's a reman efest station of the
wild principalities that i've called
them these principalities which are not
attached to the center principalities
which have a let's say a mind of their
of its own of their own and and that are
leading towards fragmentation and
towards chaos and those will be what we
call demons they they they are are
related to our passions our passions for
power with our passions for sexual
gratification those two things together
our passions for violence and and that
those passions represent themselves in
different forms one of the form of
course is rape one of the form is sexual
domination one of the form is
cannibalism cannibalism is the ultimate
image of devouring someone else in order
to acquire power for yourself and as you
start to to free focus on power let's
say external power as you move away from
that inner center and you look towards
outer forces one of the things you
notice is that power comes from
devouring it from other things you know
even your own body you get power in your
body by eating by eating things that
come from the outside and and they you
can then represent that also
symbolically that whatever power you get
you get from imposing your power from
taking someone else's power that is not
necessarily bad it can be it can be good
I've used the military example before a
military general is using the power of
his men in order to increase his
capacity to act in the world
now it doesn't necessarily have to be
bad but it definitely can be bad and
when we use the example of cannibalism
that's when we see how it can be bad how
an in crewing of power in yourself can
be the devouring of somebody else okay
you see the same with the the idea of of
human sacrifice and of especially
infanticide now as you move as you move
towards paganism it is in that it is
inevitable that infanticide reappears
I've been saying this since I was 20
years old that it is inevitable that as
Christianity falls away there are some
things which will reappear infanticide
which is a traditional practice in many
many pagan cultures and then also
suicide or let's say suicide of the
elderly will also be something which
will reappear which was also a normal
part of many many ancient pagan
traditions and so those things are going
to reappear now in terms of the way that
he represents it it's very difficult
because he he doesn't seem he really
wants to always use kind of scientific
language so he talks about other
dimensions and he talks about spaceships
and and flying saucers and all of this
and he he wants his symbolism to
represent material things and so for
example in the podcast he talks about
the the vision of Ezekiel and he's
saying how Ezekiel is seeing you know
basically wheels within wheels right in
these wheels within wheels are flying
saucers and so it's probably best to
understand to understand the opposite to
understand why the flying saucer has
become such a marked image in our
representation of extraterrestrials and
if UFOs
why why has this flying saucer become
the image of the UFO and I have to admit
that I haven't totally figured that one
out but to me that seems like the the
best move to to make now the one thing
that people are going to ask me is am I
am I saying first of all that he's full
of you know he's delusional I don't
think he's delusional I think that his
intuition about what's happening in the
world is absolutely correct
the idea that we have created a society
of human sacrifice the if you cannot get
away from the fact that that abortion
can often act as a form of human
sacrifice you just can't get away from
it because you see someone who who makes
the bet that they will have more power
in the world they will have a better
life if they get rid of this unborn
child that is a form of human sacrifice
you can't get away from it yet getting
the fact that you sacrifice one another
life for your own is a form of human
sacrifice and so he is totally right in
that now whether or not this has reached
the level of ritualized human sacrifice
that Alex Jones suggests I don't know I
have no idea I'm not in those you know
we're not in those circles we all of
this becomes hearsay and rumor and and
and all that and and it and it doesn't
and even though that it's this here
saying rumor it's not surprising that it
goes in that direction and it it
wouldn't be that surprising if it ended
up being true because those people who
understand the power of ritual and who
are looking to acquire power to
themselves it would not be surprising
that at some point they understand how
this has always been a manner to acquire
power and you can see it in everyday
life it's not sim ritual does not differ
from everyday life it is a condensation
of everyday principles into a very
synthetic form which is meant to to
let's say concentrate it so that
it has more effect and so whether or not
there are ritual human sacrifices all of
this stuff I don't know I knows you know
this is conspiracy theory but it's the
most important thing for us in terms of
those who study symbolism is to notice
how coherent the examples that he's
using are to be able to see beyond the
language of flying saucers and aliens
and everything and understand about the
connection between the foreign the
strange the alien the demon all of those
all of the all of those things you know
go together if you're interested in that
I did make a video called the symbolism
of aliens which tries to show
systematically how in our stories even
in our modern stories about
extraterrestrials how all of those
things fit together and so you know I
would say we always have to take some of
the things obviously we have to take the
things that Alex Jones says with a
serious grain of salt when he's talking
if your purpose is to understand the
world objectively but if you want to
understand let's say the symbolic
structure that are laying themselves out
around us today and and you're attentive
to what something someone like Alex
Jones says you can get a good sense of
what's happening in the world and that
this is not what he said what he's
saying is not arbitrary and it does fit
these these patterns it seems like Alex
Jones is a kind of either unknowingly or
who knows how he is a kind of let's say
someone who is tapped in to to how to
these patterns and can Intuit them very
well
now obviously do not listen to Alex
Jones and when he talks about you know
his idea of God and that God is a is a
is a is a like a comet you know in
time-space and and that the devil is
behind and and you know God is in front
and that the whole world it's like don't
take that for it Christian theology look
at the image that he's representing and
notice that it's not completely insane
if you see it in terms of a symbolic
structure he
about this comet and so you can imagine
it as a hierarchy with a point at the
end which is moving forward and then as
the comet as as the that you get further
and further away from the the head of
the comet then the effect of the comet
loses its its you know it loses its
coherence and becomes to be more and
more chaotic and the further you go then
the debris of the comet starts to fall
away and starts to not be connected to
the comet and so although it seems
insane when he says something like that
in terms of of imagining a physical
comet and thinking that that's God if
you if you can see it symbolically
which I don't know if he does or if he
is a that much of a materialist but if
you if you under sea what he's talking
about in terms of how reality lays
itself out and he talks about Satan is
in the back and you know he's he's kind
of he's lost I mean he's basically lost
the the the the effect of being
connected to the center and so because
of that he wants to subvert the the
centers like that all of that makes
total sense if you understand it in
terms of a symbolic structure but it's
but but the problem is that because
maybe even himself definitely us we have
becoming capable of understanding the
patterns and understanding those
symbolic structures because of that
what's interesting is that so many
people like to listen to him speak that
that podcast that he made yesterday is
blowing up millions of views just in a
few days so much that media outlets like
Forbes or Newsweek feel forced to write
articles about it why is it that people
are fascinating by hearing these stories
it is because just like when we watch
movies just like when we read stories
that have a a coherent symbolic
structure even though they look crazy at
first glance this is what we hear when
we hear Alex Jones talking about psychic
vampires and and all of this thing the
the structure in which he embeds all of
this is actually more coherent than we
might think and so and so let's see if
this video
it's banned because I'm not you know I'm
talking about Alex Jones in a somewhat
positive light and so and so yeah and
you know if ever Alex Jones if you ever
I know it it seems impossible but you I
have been on Infowars before not your
show but if you ever see this it is
something that I would like to talk to
you about and see if we can if we can
come to if we can come to understand
some of the things that you're talking
about in terms of their pattern and so
guys thanks for thanks for following me
as you noticed I've been putting out a
lot more content and it is something
that I hope to keep up
I appreciate everybody's support and and
the the engagement that you are putting
into this and so thanks again guys and
I'll see you soon